hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter two of utilitarianism John
Stuart Mill is presenting a number of
different criticisms of the utilitarian
theory and philosophy and then he's
trying to address each of these sort of
grabbing each bull by the horns and
trying to throw the ball down one of the
most trenchant objections to
utilitarianism is one that was made to
other hedonistic than his pleasure
valuing moral theories that they were
philosophies fit for pigs and people
said this about Epicurus he mentions
that there they actually got a cure it's
wrong if you read about the curious it's
kind of an extension fellow and so does
philosophy but when we think of that
idea Tillet area so in the Benthamite
formation it does sound very much like
if we can bring about more pleasure than
pain by say giving a lot of people
shoddy goods and mediocre
and depriving you know say a few people
there are really really great goods and
experiences so that we can spread and
spread out they're just great balance of
pleasure over pain and therefore that
would be it would be good not only allow
good and it does seem an enlarged
respect like you know with Bentham now
these because of this we've had down a
calculus if you can just be added enough
other units and pleasure and you can
turn any experience into to every
experience into an experience it should
be pursuit of the treaty produced that
should be advocated middle introduces a
different notion that a qualitative
differences between higher and lower
pleasures this is a radical Reformation
audience Oh terrorism this is one of the
key dividing lines between Mills theory
and Bentham's theory now with respect to
cases where there aren't qualitative
differences that matter the middle is
just following along with that so if
it's a question of chewing gum and how
to make the flavors of you to see you
know people like this flavor better or
this flavor better more people like this
flavor let's make that flavor that would
be the the right thing to do fairly
trivial instance but captures a point
quite well should we put out a bunch of
flocking movies or a few really great
movies each year just considered now in
terms of artistic value and not in terms
of how much they make you think but they
just in terms of what they call
production right should we put a number
of different camcorders in the hands of
a whole bunch of people and have them
make movies or should we invest in
massive studios
without just a few movies each if that
would be the way to think about that
sort of thing and men would say well in
cases like that reaction to look at what
is it maybe give people the most
pleasure yeah
what is great to remove the most pain we
can talk about this in terms of public
talk about the decisions military action
there's all sorts of things and you'll
notice that when it comes to Bentham I
actually have been produced a number of
videos going through examples to
militarism but there are some
differences between higher and lower
pleasures there are some pleasures that
are qualitatively better than other
pleasures where do we draw the dividing
lines who draws was like that I'm going
to talk about that in another concert
video certain judges are you yeah but
how are these lines to drip drawn and
what is the basis so he says he's
staying with the Epicureans when it's
hacked by being called pigs the
Epicureans have always answered that
it's not thing but their accusers who
represent human nature and integrating
life the accusation supposes human
beings are capable of no pleasures
except those which swine are capable and
now let those actually klostermann you
know pigs are pretty high-level animals
they actually can enjoy it quite a bit
you know they they are omnivores they in
the wild they actually seem to enjoy
hunting and they play with each other
they enjoy rolling around a model that's
more enough to protect their bodies
they're just
but for its own sake they also enjoy
being clean they enjoy eating all sorts
of things as a matter of fact that like
not us and that they can eat a wide
range of foods you know awesome the
goats and pigs matter of fact Kingsley
tops do everything their chance and they
took sex they enjoy a nice weather so
there's quite a few things that they do
there's a wide range of employers so if
human beings are capable of no pleasures
except that those were swine are capable
then that would be a valid criticism
against utilitarianism and he says if
the sources of pleasure were precisely
the same that human beings into swine
the rule of life which is good enough
for the one would be good enough for the
other so if that's really the case and
you're a hedonist then you know as well
they drink be merry eat drink and be
merry it gives much you know wine women
and song or beer guys right you get the
general idea but once you just try to
indulge the body as much as possible and
have as much as much fun and try to
remove as much painting as possible but
he says the comparison of the epicurean
life to that of the beasts is felt as
degrading by the critics who are making
that comparison it's felt to be
degrading why because human beings are
capable of more that key question from
Elvis do we feel pleasure in doing that
he thinks in terms of faculties how are
we different from the animals and I
don't want to get in a wine down
that's things like what about the
telephones or what about chimpanzees if
we're gonna do that we will talk about
occupying pigs and other animals to
observe they're pretty as well it's
pretty clear that at least with respect
to these things we have more development
than those animals in general I can say
all human beings necessarily across the
board but certainly most well we share
in common with the animals are our
lowered facilities what mill calls
sensibility and what it means by
sensibility is not just you know our
eyes and ears skin and stuff like that
it's all the experiences including those
that produce pleasure and pain that come
to us via the senses and that are
primarily about what we're getting
through the senses there's no like
greater meaning you could say than what
we're sensing I think about reading a
book for example you're reading a book
your eyes are actually engaged we're
running over these black and white
letters and swimming they're very
generic boy yeah you're giving a
physical reaction things are coming to
you through the senses but there's
something more involved there there's a
meaning to those to those letters you're
putting them together to make words and
from words sentences and from sentences
paragraphs and you are engaging in
replicating within yourself some of the
thoughts that the author has put down as
composed that's a higher order kind of
activity primarily intellectual activity
although I don't want those productivity
also a production of imagination mill
says human beings have faculties more
elevated than the animal appetites and
desires and when once made conscious of
them do not regard anything as happiness
which
inclu their gratification so once you
actually begin to enjoy intellectual
life now you've got something you know
clarifications about this later on both
environments and social mores things
like that but just follow with me here
he says once you've actually started to
enjoy the world of the intellect safety
or education you know talking about
ideas you can't turn off your desire
that you're not going to be fully happy
unless that isn't being gratified just
as much as physical things like getting
massages eating you know tasty food and
having nice views and join balmy weather
you know all that sort of stuff
likewise you know the imagination or
feeling the world sentiments Mills says
that the pleasures of the intellect the
pleasures of the feeling and imagination
and of the Moral Sentiments have a much
higher value and pleasures so the
qualitative difference in the kind of
pleasure that they give us in the way in
which it's satisfying not a quantitative
difference I would do clear difference
of intensity or duration the way that
Bentham talked about it is calculus but
a qualitative difference that raises it
to a higher level a much higher value as
pleasures than those of mere sensation
so we're going to talk about what he
what he means by differences of quality
of pleasures when we get to the talking
about judge and how they be actually
engaging that he is focused on talking
about cultivation or or development and
it's something that we need he says this
is a little bit later a cultivated mind
I don't mean that I'm a philosopher but
anymore
intuition of fountains of knowledge of
an open and which is the taught any
tolerable degree to exercise its
faculties its abilities find sources of
an inexhaustible interest in all that
surrounds in the objects of nature the
incidence of history the waves of
mankind past and present and their
prospects in the future it is possible
and need to become indifferent to all of
this but only when one has he have from
the beginning no moral or human interest
of these things and has slotted that
only the gratification of curiosity so
curiosity actually is involved with
these lower faculties as well what's
going on here is some sort of engagement
some sort of you know use of what is
distinctively human and when we're doing
that we're more active with this sort of
stuff that we are with mere
accessibility or giving with curiosity
there were more passive were acted upon
by the objects or the persons were doing
things so myth says that somebody who
actually knows the difference between
these will not accept any amount of
these kinds of pleasures as a substitute
for these kinds of pleasures for the
higher pleasures you could substitute
things at this lower level for each
other yeah presumably you could
substitute other higher pleasures for
each other
well don't read this book read this book
instead
don't listen to this pleasure it's a
higher plane but between these is called
this is about as sophisticated as it
gets with the it's not like he thinks
that the pleasures of the intellect
necessarily higher the pleasures
wallowing the Moral Sentiments he
doesn't he doesn't develop this much
further he does say one thing that is
very interesting and important I think
he's talking about human dignity he and
he says no intelligent person would
contempt consent to be a fool don't
instructed person would be an ignoramus
no person of learning and conscience
would be selfish and base even though
they should be persuaded that the fool
the Ducks are the rascal is better
satisfied with his lot than they are the
Third's
there are a lot of uncultivated people
who seem to be pretty satisfied a lot
pretty satisfied with what they're
getting but that's because they haven't
actually experienced higher pleasures
where they don't value them yeah says a
being of higher faculties requires were
to make him happy and it's probably
capable of a more acute suffering
certainly accessible to it at more
points than one of an inferior type but
in spite of these liabilities he can
never really wish to sink into what he
feels a lower grade of existence so what
we're talking about here are actual
grades of existence as human beings we
can decide whether we want to be mere
animals or whether we really want to be
human distinctively and that takes
cultivating this part of ourselves that
takes value this and working and
choosing it over and over again he says
we may give what explanation we please
of this unwillingness we may attribute
it to pride we may refer it to the love
of Liberty and personal and
pendants but the most profit appellation
name is a sense of dignity which all
human beings possess in one form or
another and some though by no means an
exact proportion of their higher
faculties so more we use our higher fact
is more that we engage in pleasures of
the higher faculties and preferring that
with the lower and sometimes sacrifices
the lower to them the greater is sense
of our own dignity we will have the
person who's down here really doesn't he
had a much of a sense of their own
dignity of their own value of their own
worth because they don't really have an
experience of what it is that human
beings are truly capable and he goes up
and he talks about the difference
between happiness and if we choose the
pleasures of the lower faculties to the
exclusion of the higher faculties
because we do have to we do have to
engage in trade-offs in life the best
that we can hope for is contentment
that is what the animals are capable of
true happiness is according to mill all
in the profits of human beings and only
the products of human beings who are
actually engaged in processes of
developing themselves and enjoying these
higher pleasures
now if follow this is the case there's
two other things that follow from this
that I want
Milas not bringing up here in this
section but he talks about in other
places in another waves
what is that if this really is the case
that we we not only want to cultivate
the higher faculties and ourselves we
also have to try to do so in others not
only those who we are directly
responsible for later on like a students
or children but inevitably we also try
to make this something that everybody
can enjoy and obtain access to that's
not to say that we should ignore rid of
or denigrate the lower pleasures they're
still pleasures are still valuable but
they're not the only thing the other
thing that I think is very important to
talk about so far we want to talk about
pleasures but we can also talk about
things we could say that there are
qualitative differences between kings as
well so some things in a boggling things
are you know some respect not as bad as
those which actually impinge upon our
higher faculties the sense of having
done something terrible to another
person that remorse the repentance that
comes with that in a certain way that's
much more painful that's something
that's a pain that we would much rather
avoid they am being physically tortured
we did wonder about what sort of pains
of correspond to the intellect or to the
imagination as well some names are going
to be more degrading to the human person
and to the dignity of the human person
that others that's where I'll leave off
with that I want to make one further
suggestion along those lines with
respect maybe one form of degradation
a force from this into the mirror having
access to the lower pleasures